agencies did respond to that plane crash
that's right fire station 53 was the
closest to the scene even though it's
about two miles away near gohen and
simmons now today firefighters took
victoria saha for a ride along and
you'll only see it here on eight news
now to show us their response and what
changes will be made in the event of a
similar incident
[Music]
when responding to an aircraft collision
just like any emergency the north las
vegas fire department has thorough
training and sunday's plane crash was
another reminder of how important it is
to be prepared but also to think on your
feet
when lights and sirens go off every
second matters and on sunday fire
captain frank sanchez knew there was no
time to waste when there was a report of
a mid-air collision involving two planes
while i'm looking at notes here i'm also
looking at the conditions of the fire we
knew we did have an emergency at the
airport their yearly aircraft collision
training was put to the test it's not
very often we have incidents here we
want to get there as quick as we can and
save as many lives as you can the fire
station is five minutes from north las
vegas airport captain sanchez says since
it is an airport for primarily private
use the faa doesn't require a fire
department on scene at all times they do
have that vehicle
here on site that has
specialized chemicals for body fire for
airplanes and foam on it and airport
officials grabbed it first while station
53 was on route as both planes were on
fire the first priority was to save
those on board and then tackle the rest
of the blaze
tower cleared us and then we went
straight to
to both planes
and unfortunately when we got there we
we did the assessment and there was
nothing that we could have
for any other victims captain sanchez
says the fire was put out within six
minutes the north las vegas fire
department will be using what happened
on sunday and implementing it into a
training course later this week
reporting in north las vegas victoria
saha live local now